بالاعلان عن هيار بنك سيليكون فالي في
كاليفورنيا الجمعه مباشره شاهدنا عملاء
ويقفون خارج شرعي في شارع سانتل الشهير في
سيليكون فالي في البرد والامطار معظم
العملاء من مؤسسيه الشركات الصغيره
والماشيه هذا المشهد ليس امريكيا فقط بل
يصل تاثيره للعالم كون فروع البنك منتشره
في الصين والمانيا والهند والسويد
والمانيا للمره الاخيره يفتح بنك اس بي بي
ابوابه اليوم الاثنين حتى يتمكن اصحاب
الودائع المؤمن عليها من الحصول على
اموالهم بحد اقصى 250 الف دولار امريكي
وطبعا الضربه عندما تصيب مؤسسه كبيره تؤثر
على الصغار في مجالها التحذيرات تاتي ايضا
من ان الازمه قد تؤدي الى هجوما مودعين
لسحب امواله من البنوك الصغيره ما يؤدي
الى افلا
[موسيقى]